[Music]
this is the story of our most excellent
dads
i'm bill s preston esquire
and i'm ted theodore logan
and where wild stallions
this was probably the first time you saw
him
[Applause]
[Music]
and this was probably the last
not long before we were born they were
told they were going to write a song
that was going to unite the entire world
which they thought they had done with
their hit single those who rock
not only did it not unite the world
but the band fell apart and our dads
alone now were trying harder and harder
but the problem was the harder dads
tried the less interested people seemed
to be in their music
not only was it wearing on them and on
the family
but the universe they were told they
were gonna bring together was actually
starting to unravel
it was bad totally dude
anyways this is how we got to where we
are
now
hello friends and loved ones let us
welcome you one and all to this most
joyous of occasions
ted and i have known missy in different
capacities for many decades
first she was our babysitter when we
were 10. then we both invited her to the
prom when she was a senior and we were
freshmen
yeah two years later she married my dad
and missy became mom after divorcing
bill's dad
she married my dad and became my mom
now she's marrying ted's little brother
officer deacon
logan
missy bill and i along with my beautiful
wife elizabeth
and our daughter billy and my beautiful
wife joanna
and our daughter thea all want to
welcome you back
with open arms
this happy event which seemed to make
deacon his own father-in-law
ted his own uncle not to mention making
my dad
his own son with that beautiful thought
in mind
for your first dance we wish to present
you with a matrimonial offering
a sneak peek at the world premiere of
our newest sonic creation
we're not sure if this is going to be
the song that unites the world
we're pretty sure might at least we hope
sure to be another real doozy from the
wild stallions
let's dance freaky dicky
you got it kissy missy your dad used to
call me that
totally wear that baby please enjoy the
first three movements of
that which binds us through time the
chemical
physical and biological nature of love
an exploration of the meaning of meaning
part one ready bill
ready ted one two one two three four
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
dad i told you a thousand times bill and
i have to keep going yeah
yeah yeah until your music unites the
world chief logan the people in the
future told
us today well bill bill you didn't time
travel we did lives aren't from medieval
england they all
you didn't go to heaven and hell we did
you didn't we did
you know why because it's impossible
here's a real idea for you too here
comes dude
get real jobs be role models to your
daughters
well never mind you are they're 24
they live at home and they're unemployed
you remember when you used to call them
little bill little ted
if you thought it was cute gramps
well it turned out to be a curse all i
ever see them do is sit around
listen to music that is our primary
activity definitely
yeah because okay joanna elizabeth
how do you feel about being the only
adults in your families
the only ones with actual jobs
let's pack up
[Music]
foreign